>>Tiffany Shlain: I'm really happy to be here
on this gorgeous New York day.I was just,
like, ah, I love New York.Um, anyways, we
open on um, Friday at the Angelica Film Center
we'll be there for a week.And we'll talk more
about that later, we have all these speakers
lined up, but.I'm really excited to share
the film with you.And see a lot of laptops
out.That was also the case at Google on the
Bay area.Which as a film maker, well when
you see film you'll know the irony of all
that.[Laughter] But, um, no, no, it's cool,
because it is cool.It's ok.Um, [laughs] but
the film is both a very personal film for
me as well as a kind of global look at what
all this connectedness means.And, um, you
know, it's been really exci-- Probably my
most exciting spreenings, screenings have
been at the tech companies because you all
are creating these tools and you have so much
influence on how we're using them and what
is it mean?
What are the implications of all the things
that you are creating?
So, uh and there's a couple, um, see if you
notice the very, the Google shot.'Cause, you
know I founded the Webby Awards.And, uh, there
might be a shot of the founders with capes
and rollerblades winning their first Webby
Award.There just might be.Anyways, um, so,
anyways it's an eight minute film and then
afterwards we'll have a good, um, discussion
afterwards, so enjoy.
>>Female Interviewer: Hello!
This is Tiffany Shlain as you met in the beginning
of the film.
>>Tiffany: You now know more about me than
you ever thought you would know.
>>Female Interviewer: Exactly.I was going
to start off with a bio but I figured that
everyone already knows everything about your
personal and professional life.So I don't
think we need to go there.
>>Tiffany: Yeah, you don't need to go over
my life, yeah.
>>Female Interviewer: I was maybe going to
share some, um, feedback that I've read about
your film.In particular, from ah, Al Gore.Ah,
he said "Tiffany Shlain demonstrates with
lyrical simplicity our interdependence on
one another and the interconnectedness of
humanity with all life on earth.Throughout
she presents and honors with deep wisdom of
her late father, Leonard Shlain reminding
us of the deepest connections that breathe
meaning into life."
And then I found another quote which I'm sorry
I don't know the author, um, I couldn't find
that.It said "A love letter to humanity and
our shared potential."
So that's quite an accomplishment to write
a love letter to humanity.So congratulations
on your film.
>>Tiffany: Thank you.Thank you so much.
Thank you.
>>Female Interviewer: It's excellent.Um, and
maybe we could start off talking about that.If
you could just tell us a little bit about
how the film started off as a documentary
and morphed into an autoblog-ography.
>>Tiffany: Yeah, yeah, this is my eighth film
and I have never made a personal film.I don't
know if I ever will again.But, um, I started
out, the film took four years to make.And,
um, I was just focusing at, we called it the
idea portion of the movie.It's all about,
just about the ideas I was interested, obviously
you know my background.I was interested in
why are we creating all these technologies?
What's our desire to connect?
And I wanted to place it in historical context
and kind of give this overview.And in year
two I sat in the editing room and got this
sinking feeling that no film maker wants to
feel as they're watching their rough cut.I
had a complete two hour movie.And I watched
it and I thought "I'm not connecting to the
material."
That it was about connectedness and I had
no emotional connectedness to what I was talking
about.The tubes are connecting us.Um, and,
so and my father had just been diagnosed and
I was really thinking a lot about connection.And
then it kind of hit me that in order to understand
connectedness of humanity I needed to understand
what I was feeling about connectedness in
my family.That that's where all of this stems
from, is our sense of feeling connected.And
we're all social creatures and that that I
needed to kind of explore my own sense of
connectedness.So then, it was a very difficult
process.I'd brought in a story editor, I have
a writing team and we spent two years.First
we looked at at the story arc in the idea
film then we made a story arc in my personal
life.Which was really weird.They're like "Well
what happened in the second act, like, was
there something worse that happened?"
And I was like--.And then we had to weave
them together but the exciting moments in
the editing room and in the writing room were
when the personal and the global clicked together.And
I realized that they were, you know, like,
growth, for growth's sake is cancer or these
moments when what was happening to me personally
were speaking to something globally.Whether
it was, you know, I think our society is so
exciting right now and something's also died
in our society.And something is about to be
born with the internet and, so there was all
these kind of parallels, um.And, of course,
I started weaving in my dad's work, which
has been so influential to me.So, it was,
you know, and our big goal with this film,
was to really get a conversation started.So
what does it mean to be connected?
What's the good?
What's the bad?
What's the hope of it?
And we made this whole, um, discussion kit
that goes with the movie.And a lot of educators
are using this right now.So it has a curriculum,
and then there's conversation cards and a
book.And we just really want people to get,
to be talking.We're all moving so quickly,
as you all know here at Google.We're just
moving a million miles an hour.And what does
it all mean?
Like we have an opportunity to kind of explore
what are the implications of our actions and
what we're building and how it's affecting
the world.And what's the potent- 'cause I
get very excited, especially with a lot of
the stuff you're doing about the collaborative
tools.And I should tell you that I can't wait
till we can get video online, but my team
is kind of all over and we wrote the script
completely on Google docs.Like, we'd all be
on at the same time writing.And, um, in different
places, in real time, it was fabulous.And,
um, but the collaborative tools are where
I get most excited about the potential of
what that could mean.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah.
>>Tiffany: For this world.
>>Female Interviewer: And speaking of the
toolkit that you have, I think it's for teachers
and things like that, so they can continue
the discussion in class.Um, you know this
generation of kids, they, all they know is
being connected.Their birth was probably announced
immediately on Facebook and, you know, tweeted
about and
>>Tiffany: Ours was, that was our birth announcement.
>>Female Interviewer: Exactly.
So what do you think it's like for those children,
I mean, you could, when you were looking at
connectedness you could go back to a time
when you remembered not being connected technology.I
mean, I think that kids--.
>>Tiffany: I mean it's a great question as
I have a two year old and an eight year old
and their whole way of processing information
is different but the good news is my daughter
still loves to read.And we do technology Shabbats
every Saturday.Very serious.And since we finished
the film, so Friday night, sundown, we light
the candles and we turn off all screens for
24 hours which has been pretty life changing
for me, for me personally, 'cause I was feeling
too much.I was slee-- in my sleep I was emailing
and texting.Like in my sleep.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah.
>>Tiffany: And my mind was just too much.So,
um, we started doing that and my kids love
it.And everyone can try it.I know it sounds
weird, but it's kind of wonderful to remember
what it's like to just be not be able to act
on every single thought you have.And what's
the one day of the week you want to feel long
is Saturday?
>>Female Interviewer: Mm-hm
>>Tiffany: And time totally slows down when
you are unplugged.So I found it's been seven
months now and it's really rebalanced me.But
going back to our children, I'm very excited.I
mean I feel like, I think we've finally created
a work environment that mirrors our stream
of consciousness, 'cause we don't think in
a linear way.Our thoughts, you're listening
to me, I'm saying things making you think
of, like, 20 different things.And that's the
way we really thing.And you know I used to
watch my father do brain surgery, that's very
focused.Eight hours.Would not leave the focus
and just asked for tools.And now we have an
environment where every thought we have can
be acted on.Every idea, every link, every,
and I think that's exciting.So, I know people
who are so worried about the distraction but
I kind of feel like, you know, when the written
word was invented, everyone worried that oral
tradition would be, we'd lose our memory.Well
we kind of lost a bit of our memory but we
gained a lot of knowledge with books.When
I was growing up television was going to destroy
our brains.I watched a lot of crappy TV.It
has not destroyed our brains.
>>Female Interviewer: Mm-hm
>>Tiffany: And, um, I just think that they're
gonna process and explore this world in a
totally new way.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah, and I feel like
technology, maybe, um, you know, it started
out where, it kind of came to us and sort
of forced its way into our life.And we use
it now and feel like it's shifting where it's
changing to adapt to how we need to use it.
>>Tiffany: Yeah, and that's what a lot of
you are doing here.That's exactly right.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah, so that's exciting.
>>Tiffany: And, um, I want, well, we can open
it up, but I want to tell you the reason we
do these preview screenings, like we're an
independent documentary.You have to see it,
I've opened in L.A. next to Brad Pitt's Moneyball.You
can imagine.
[interviewer chuckles]
>>Tiffany: They have a lot of marketing money.I
was like 'Oh my God'.There's like twenty billboards
in L.A.And like our but, you know, our film
has done really well through social networking.And,
um, it's been very exciting.So if you liked
the movie, we open at the Angelica on Friday.We've
all these exciting speakers.Every night, kind
of approaching connectedness from their perspectives.So
we have Anna Deavere Smith, we have designer
Todd Oldham, um, we have MeetUp founder Scott
Heiferman, film producer Ted Hope.We have
all these great people.And every night our
goal is to really start a dialog from a different
perspective.I mean, obviously if you saw any
of the film, you could approach this subject
from, you're an environmentalist, if you're
a technologist, if you're a woman, if, you
know, it's just we just want to crack open
the dialog.And we hope that you will either
come opening weekend, it's all about opening
weekend for independent docs.
(Interviewer chuckles)
>>Tiffany: Bring your friends.And, or just
spread the word, we'd be super, super grateful.
>>Female Interviewer: And what else was on
the little cards that you were handing out?
>>Tiffany: Um, the card was just kind of,
you guys all know this, like spoon feeding,
well can I just tell you I can't wait till
you guys have a Google plus for films?
'Cause you don't have that yet and we've been
having a lot of fun with having extending
the Q and A outside of the theater online.So
we've been having in our Facebook page but
I'm dying for you guys to have the, uh, ability
on Google plus to carry on the dialog and
the hangouts for films.Um, but on the cards,
it kind of says how you can post things, tweet,
Google plus, whatever you can to get it out
to your networks that we're going to be in
the theater for a week in New York.
>>Female Interviewer: Okay.Great.Um, and then
before we open up to questions do you want
to show the short film?
>>Tiffany: Do you guys want, ok, so I made
this film it was very much with YouTube, so
I thought it would be fun to show it.Do you
guys want to see a little four minute crowd
source film we made?
It's called the Declaration of Interdependence.It's,
uh, Moby did the music.It's, we'd, it just
we made it about five weeks ago.We posted
something on the internet.We wrote a script,
a one minute script and everyone participated
and, um, we showed it at interdependence day
in New York right after 9/11, it premiered.
[ Music playing]
>>Male #1: When in the course of human events
>>Male #2: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #3: In the course of human events
>>Female #1: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #4: [speaking French]
>>Male #5: [speaking foreign language]
>>Female #2: [speaking Spanish]
>>Male #6: To recognize the fundamental qualities
>>Male #7: [speaking foreign language]
>>Female #3: That connects us
>>Female #4: That connects us
>>Female #5: That connects us
>>Male #8: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #9: The truths we hold
>>Female #6: To be self-evident
>>Female #7: [speaking foreign language]
>>Female #8: That all humans are
>>Male #10: created equal
>>Female #9: And all are connected
>>Male #11: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #12: That we share the pursuit of life
>>Female #10: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #13: Liberty
>>Male #14: [speaking Hebrew]
>>Female #11: Happiness
>>Male #15: [speaking foreign language]
>>Female #12: [speaking foreign language]
>>Female #13: Water.
>>Female #14: Agua.
>>Female #15: Shelter
>>Female #16: Refugio.
>>Crowd: Safety
>>Female #17: Seguridad.
>>Male #16: Education
>>Male #17: Pendidikan
>>Female #18: Justice
>>Male #18: And hopes for a better future
>>Group of women: That our collective knowledge
>>Group #1: Economy
Technology
And environment
>>Group #2: Are fundamentally interdependent
>>Male #19: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #20: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #21: That what will propel us forward
>>Female #19: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #22: Is our curiosity
>>Female #20: Curiosite.
>>Female #21: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #23: Our ability to forgive.
>>Male #24: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #25: Our ability to appreciate
>> Female #22: Our courage
>>Male #26: Our courage.
>>Female #23 [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #27: And our desire to connect [echoes]
[bell tingles]
>>Female #24: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #28: [speaking foreign language]
>>Female #25: That these things we share
>>Female #26: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #29: To our fullest common potential
>>Male #30: [speaking foreign language]
>>Female #27: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #31: We should never take ourselves
too seriously
>>Female #28: [speaking foreign language]
>>Female #29: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #32: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #33: So that we can learn from the
past
>>Male #34: Understand our place in the world
>>Female #30: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #35: [speaking foreign language]
>>Female #31: Use our collective knowledge
>>Group #3: Use our collective knowledge
>>Male #36: To create a better future
>>Male #37: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #38: So perhaps it's time
>>Female #32: [speaking foreign language]
>>Male #39: That we as a species
>>Female #33: As a species
>>Male #40: [wheezing laughter] Love to laugh
>>Male #41: [speaking foreign language]
>>Female #34: Love to laugh.
>>Male #42: [speaking French]
>>Female #35: Ask questions
>>Female #36:And connect
>>Male #43: Do something radical
And true
For centuries
>>Female #37: we have declared
>>Male #44: Independence
>>Male #45: Perhaps it's now time
>>Male #46: That we
>>Male #47: As humans
>>Male #48: Declare our interdependence
>>Female #36: Interdependence
>>Male #49: Interdependence
>>Male #50: [speaking foreign language]
[various people continue saying "Interdependence"]
>>Whole group: Interdependence.
[ music playing ]
[dramatic music with female vocals]
[marker goes "boing" on map]
[music with female vocals]
>>Tiffany: So that film kind of picked up
where connected left off and it's gonna be
a series of six short films or eight that
kind of deal with interdependence, but it
was really fun to, you know, we posted that
and it's already been translated into fifty
languages, um.And, you know, again it's the
collaborative tools that you all are creating,
as a film maker are super exciting.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah
>>Tiffany: We should open it up.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah, um, so there are
two microphones, here, so if anyone has any
questions please, uh, make your way to the
mic.Thanks.
>>Male Audience Member #1: Hi, uh my first
question is where do we buy the tickets for
Friday?
[Tiffany and Interviewer laugh]
>>Tiffany: I don't even know him!
[Laughter]
>>Male Audience Member #1: You do, but online.
[laughter]
>>Tiffany: Oh, awesome, uh, cool [laughs]
[Laughter]
>>Tiffany: So tickets were supposed to go
on sale today, like everyone's running and
the Angelica's like not selling them till
tomorrow, um, so, if you go to connec-- I
was gonna say it, I'm not gonna say your Facebook
page, go to connectedthefilm.com and, um,
tickets are gonna go on sale tomorrow.We hope
you'll bring friends.It's really fun to watch
with a group.And anytime during opening weekend,
the premier happens Friday night, but if you
have the inclination to bring people, any
screening during Friday, Saturday or Sunday's
really helpful.Thank you.
>>Male Audience Member #1: Sure.And, uh, my
other question, or my, is, uh, in the film
I was fundamentally optimistic, uh, and, uh,
you showed a lot of footage from, like, the
Civil Rights and, uh, JFK and the space program
and stuff like that which was great.But, uh,
in the last ten years, especially, there's
been a lot of other stuff going on, uh, you
know, the film sort of had a--
>>Tiffany: It leaves on an optimistic note
>>Male Audience Member #1: Yeah, and, uh,
you looked at the arc of history as you sort
of sighted as progressive.You, uh-
>>Tiffany: I do believe, I mean, you know,
that's been the most interesting thing is
that the screenings tell how pessimistic a
lot of people are.And I guess, if you just
watch the news it would look like a pretty
horrible world that we live in.It's like it
highlights the worst of humanity and I think
that you could and I think that it's also
important that we highlight some of the potential
of humanity.So I did put in the movie you
know this connectedness that's led to the
atomic bomb and all this news, but we didn't
blow ourselves up and we could've.And I ultimately
believe in the human species.I believe we're
moving the needle forward.The fact that I'm
a woman director up here right now means that
women's rights happened that meant so many
things had to happen for me to be sitting
here.I'm a Jew, my family almost died, you
know, we're evolving.Gay rights, I mean, I
just feel, like we're moving the needle forward.So,
if you believe that fundamentally and you
say and we have this tool that's gonna to
have the potential in our lifetimes to connect
every person on the planet.What could that
world look like?
'Cause you have to at least imagine that in
order for it to happen.So I guess I hear you
that I am not Pollyanna in my sense of like
"Oh the internet is going to save the world."
There's been a couple articles that I was
like 'Ok'.So, people are going to save where
we go.The internet is an extension of the
human spirit.There's this great quote it's
like "Technology is neither good nor bad nor
neutral."
It's us.It's just us, like, telescope you
couldn't see far enough and our brains couldn't
grow big enough so we connect.So I just feel
like we can we have agency and we can direct
it and I hope that not only we talk about
it but we kind of direct it in a good way.So
I do leave on an optimistic note, 'cause I
am actually optimistic.I know it's rare these
days but.There's a great book called the Rational
Optimist by Matt Ridley, has anyone read that.And
he looks at throughout history and civilization
that innovation has always happened in cities
because the more people are next to each other
from different perspectives and that's usually
when big inventions happened all throughout
civilization.So we have the internet now,
that the potential is that we have this framework
for all these people to bump up against each
other from different perspectives and I think
that could hopefully solve some of our biggest
problems if we use it that way.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah, seems as though
it has to evolve.I mean it had to have this
sort of big explosion before everyone figures
out where the pieces land.How to use it to
the best--
>>Tiffany: Right and I think we're-- You know
I used to be a smoker, not proud of it.But
I used to smoke a lot and I think, you know,
I quit like twelve years ago or fourteen years
ago.Sometimes I think like God, I can't believe
I smoked first thing in the morning or on
the plane.Remember when everyone was smoking
on the plane, like that's so gross.But I wonder
if we're going to look back on the way we
use social media way too much and be like,
I can't believe that person texted at a funeral,
like that is so rude!
Which I was at a funeral last week and saw
someone texting and, but I just feel like
how we swung way, 'cause we're just so intoxicated
with all this stuff and it swung so far in
this way of there's no boundaries there's
no like, no that's not cool to use it then.And
I wonder about that.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah, where the pieces
will fall.
>>Tiffany: Well the other thing about smoking--Did
anyone smoke in here, used to be a smoker?
No one?
Oh my God.
[Chuckling]
>>Tiffany: Ok I'm not going to use my other
-- none of you have ever smoked?
Wow!
See, we have evolved.Ok do you remember when
you'd be smoking and while you were smoking
you would think I want another cigarette while
the cigarette was in your mouth.That's the
way social media is to me.Like I'm doing something
and I'm wanting to do something else.It's
that same kind of addictive thing.I cannot
believe only two people in this room smoked.Well
that's, we've evolved.We learned that was
bad for us.Everyone used to smoke.Doctors
used to smoke.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah and you mentioned
that too, even cell phones, like when we're
kind of the guinea pigs.Right?
>>Tiffany: Yeah, I do think about that.I really
do use my earbuds, 'cause I think 'that much
radiation against the brain' I don't think
that's good.And you know, the reason I put
that scene in, you know when my daughter,
they were, my dad was so against her getting
an MRI.Because, you know, radiation it's like
unclear on what that is doing.It's a lot of
uses of it and I'm actually, I'm not paranoid
about it, but I definitely use an earbud and
don't let my baby hold the phone to her head.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah, which is very
hard to do, because every baby wants to play
with your cell phone.
>>Tiffany: I know, she asked me, she's like
"Can I have some, can I have some phone?"
like she was asking for a lollipop.Can I have
some phone?
I was like, oh my God, she was like, wanted
it so badly.
[Laughs]
>>Female Interviewer: The other thing in your
films, uh, you use a lot of archived footage,
which is wonderful, it's also very logical,
because it's economical, because you don't
have to go out and shoot that footage.What
I was thinking in this film was how interesting
it is that you're showing old, 'cause it's
showing how connected we are.
You can make, you know, make these assumptions,
make these connections between old footage
and how interesting.
>>Tiffany: To me, that's, you know, it actually
came from at Berkley, UC Berkley where I went
to school.There was no film production there.So
I actually had to make movies by recutting
old movies and then it kind of informed my
whole film making style.And now with the internet
I used to have to actually search for shots
and now I'm just like a kid in a candy store.I'm
on the web, I'm like, archival shot from the
'20s and like 20 images come up.So it's super
fun for me and but I also feel like I wanna
ground, I try to ground people in history,
'cause that's another thing that we're so
not thinking about, the past.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah and I think that's
another wonderful thing about your film is
that it you give such a history and you're
teaching while then coming back and making
connections.Not to overuse the word with uh,
you know, your personal life and things.And
like I think your father had said, you know,
if you wanna go look for connections in the
past--
>>Tiffany: That was always the way he approached
anything he was really, he always, I mean
even when he started working on Leonardo da
Vinci I was like why are you, why are you
writing about Leo-- I really actually didn't
get it at first, like, why are so fascinated
with Leonardo da Vinci?
'Cause there's been so many books about Leonardo
da Vinci it was like it was like he was writing
a new book that hadn't been written.But he
did have a new, like he really thought Leonardo
da Vinci was like offering the future of our,
a glimpse into the future of our species.And
so he had to understand what made Leonardo
tick.I mean it's interesting.It is interesting
way to approach problems or the world.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah, yeah.Please.
>>Male Audience Member #2: Hi there.
>>Female Interviewer: Hi
>>Male Audience Member #2: I'm very excited
for the future with the way technology's moving
so fast and I'm sure many other people are
here as well.At the same time I'm very concerned
about how it's just as you've mentioned it
spiraled out of control.I really enjoyed your
film because you've discussed the mindfulness
of or just being mindful about how technology,
how we use it, things like that.Now a common
problem I run into with friends, is their
all, like, in technology and stuff and I'm
trying to tell them we have to be, we have
to watch what we're doing.Things like that,
or that things become so well established
now.And if you contradict that you end up
sounding crazy.And I often do, so how do you,
how do you pass along this message?
>>Tiffany: Yeah, I mean, we're, the good news
I can tell you is we've had premiers all over
the country and people are ready to talk about
it.You know I feel like I'm bringing up, even
the way I start the movie and we've all done
that right?
Right?
[Laughs] No, you're like with someone and
you go check your email in the bathroom 'cause
you're jonesing for an email hit.And I a lot
of people said it's like you called me out,
you know, 'cause I'm talking about the thing
that we're all doing and um, people are ready
to talk about it.It's a very active dialog
in the feeders and online about it afterwards
'cause I feel like we're at that point where
we need to talk about it.And when I mention
the technology Shabbats people look at me
like I'm an alien.They're like, you unplug
every week?
And they're like, well I do that on vacation
once a year.I'm like, no it's about doing
every week is really what it's about, for
me.It's like a muscle you need to exercise,
you're mind back into being in the garden
and reading and sitting with yourself, which
is beautiful.And different and profound also.So,
I guess I feel like I'm trying to, I agree
with you.I'm extremely excited and I also
think we need to be mindful and conscious
as humans, but I believe we can do that.
>>Male Audience Member #2: Thanks.
>>Tiffany: Yeah, thank you.
>>Female Interviewer: Then use technology
in order to have that time when you're in
the garden.Because you don't have to be at
your desk, you can answer the email, done,
ok put it away, now go take a walk.
>>Tiffany: Yeah, I mean being a woman is so,
you know, great to be a woman today and I
can pick up my kids from school and have all
this freedom with technology to work in a
different way, but we also, you know, we are
distracted, from what's right, the people
right in front of us.
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah
>>Tiffany: On that note I have to go to a--
>>Female Interviewer: Yeah, you have another
event.Thank you very much, thank you for coming
and sharing your film.
>>Tiffany: Thank you so much, you're a great
audience.Thank you and thank you for the great
questions.
It was great.
[applause]